ai and voice is going to be game
changing the way that our grandparents
look at an iphone
a lot of you are going to look at ai
voice that way it's going to change your
life
you got your perspective
[Applause]
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
so gary thank you again um like we said
my name is drew i'm on the marketing
team here at fibo there's also lillian
at the top as well as betty or cmo
um i'm really excited to both
ask you a lot of some pre-submitted
questions that people have been
submitting over the last
uh several weeks and we'll also pull up
a couple people to
ask you some stuff on their own so so
let's yeah let's get into it
um i think there's a good opportunity to
sort of kick off this
this hour with asking you sort of a
wide-ranging question right there's been
a lot of change over the last year
where uh we've historically been fivo in
the
live entertainment and school space yep
and i think there's a good
uh a good way to kick it off is what are
some of the consumer engagement trends
that you've seen whether they've changed
or how their how this past year has has
set up for the future
i mean the the impact of covid
on consumer behavior is extraordinary
like i promise you that every single
person here
is grossly underestimating the impact of
it
and it's not as simple as like we're not
in the office or live event like
by show of hands and i'll try to go fast
on the 22 screens here
by show of hands how many people here
have bought something on the internet as
a consumer good like a toothpaste a
deodorant shampoo
food that they had never bought before
pre-covered because they were buying
hold up i mean do you understand how big
of a deal that is
every hand going up it also means that
you might be ordering from seamless or
post mates or ubereats from a restaurant
locally that you tried that now becomes
your main restaurant not the one
i mean this is a big deal like i'm no
longer gonna fly to madrid and give a
keynote
and then leave right away i'm gonna
actually enjoy madrid
for two days because i'm gonna work from
zoom
back in new york during the day but like
not like
this is big big right and
and i think anybody who doesn't realize
that
is because they're worried that it's
going to hurt their business
and they just want it to go back to 2019
but they're not paying attention to the
human being
this is going to affect companies i mean
there's some big cool there's some big
companies
google down that have over 50 of their
their employees telling them they don't
want to ever come back to the office
ever
and then there's a bunch of people here
that want to punch their kids in the
mouth and can't wait to get back to the
office like you know how it is i get it
but but just because you might go back
to normal in your mind
even though you've already made plenty
of new decisions that you don't even
realize
let there be no confusion on the flip
side
every live event in 2022 is gonna act
exactly like it did in 2019
all of them like we're not gonna not
like it's just we're humans
we're gonna congregate you know um
could some people decide they don't want
to go sure
i would argue there's a lot of people
that realize how much they love
sporting events and concerts during this
time and may double
up in 2022 and 2023 so
those are some of the themes that are
running through my head it's funny
actually
i was talking to ari about this exact
thing last week and he said the exact
same thing there's going to be a lot of
pent-up demand for not being able to do
these things over the last
year and a half year or whatever oh my
god everybody who used to complain about
sitting in traffic for an hour when they
went to the washington football team
game
you know is now that's right you know
that was for you is now
um is now going to be thrilled
to sit in that traffic after two years
you you we
you know so i i think there's gonna be
some really extreme consumer habits
consumption habits i've watched more
[ __ ] tv in the last
12 months that i've watched the last 12
years you know um
i've added hbo max and hulu and like you
know that's
you know so there's just so many things
i think i play chess now
because of queen's gambit something i
wouldn't even watched had there not been
coveted
that like just think about that [ __ ]
yeah
it's it's very interesting so in
thinking of the way our days
and our routines have changed what
has changed in your own daily routine
that you've either picked up
and you want to continue or you found
yourself falling off from
you know i love people which is why i
think social media
when you don't just use it as a blast
thing was so real for me
i've been shocked by like even notice
what i did with chanel just now and i'm
clicking around right i see
like i'm looking at sarah houston right
now i'm looking at jake venice
you know i'm looking at randy asks like
i'm looking right because i need human
interaction i've been blown away
paul b's in the building i've been blown
away by how much i can feel y'all
in this format it's not a hundred but
it's [ __ ]
96 and in that 96 it's gonna change a
lot of things for me
right i'm gonna be much more efficient
with meetings you know
i play in vip life i'm trying to get to
dinner with a ceo to make things happen
sometimes it takes me and her nine
months to lock in
that's easy now on zoom over a glass of
wine
i mean my business development has
changed forever
i'm going to be far more efficient using
the internet to go figure
to to win that game because now
everyone's used to zoom life
and i think this mixed world of zoom
life in real life is very real now
and i think that um i think that's going
to be
the biggest change how i manage my time
because i'm going to be able to use
virtual
as a weapon to be more efficient no more
waking up at 4 30 in the morning for
one meeting in chicago on the 6 a.m
flight for 12 30 in chicago and flying
back at 16
that's [ __ ] stupid and that's going
to be pretty cool which will lead to
incredible impact
more time with my kids i'm going to
catch more basketball games at 4 30
because i'm in the city
and not in chicago um just
more efficiency i'm ecstatic
there's something too in that that we've
talked about a lot with some of our
collegiate partners
and the idea of how alumni networks now
you know there might have been a
i went to maryland right so there was a
new york city alumni
event or an la alumni event now your
reach as a college marketer
is instantly across the country and it
pulls in a lot more people which is
which is a good example of that i think
everything wins when you eliminate
friction
you know why you love amazon because it
eliminates friction
convenience is king this was established
a long time ago
what what what this culture of virtual
is going to do
is going to eliminate friction there are
a lot of things that you used to not go
to
because you just couldn't make it then
you're just going to go into the zoom
part
they're going to be many events that are
going to be half zoom half real
a for a 400 networking event right now i
genuinely believe
will be 137 people in a room and a
screen with what we're
all looking at right now and we're doing
our thing here and then you know it's
it's mixed i hate when people everyone's
like it's gonna be this or it's gonna be
this
there's no there's no extreme it's gonna
be the middle
it's gonna be mixed and i think there's
a chance to make real life events
far more interesting and i'm excited
about it
so let's dive into that a little bit so
real life events
again looking at the sports through a
sports lens
how is that hybrid virtual and real life
experience going to change in the future
i
i own coaches club seats for the new
york jets and pay a fortune for
it and i would pay an extra thousand
dollars
per game to be in the locker room
virtually
for a jets game now
they can get pretty gangster in those
locker rooms after the game so i don't
know if that's gonna be the thing the
jets decide to sell
but but if i'm an artist if i ever if i
had the luxury
of being drake right
and i'm a businessman i'm selling
fifteen hundred dollars ahead virtual
passes
for a cam in my green room
during my tour for the whole tour now
if i'm doing crazy [ __ ] or [ __ ] the
money i need my relaxation i'm not
but for garyvee knowing my personality
because i'm not doing dumb [ __ ] i'm not
trying to do
bad [ __ ] and i'm addicted to [ __ ]
human interaction i'm [ __ ] doing that
all day long
right so it you know it's it's really
going to be an interesting thing it's
completely
opened up things and what i'm excited
about is some of the people that are
getting hurt the most
artists venues teams i think they're
going to win the most in 2025
because they're going to innovate on top
they've just found a ton of revenue
that the limitations of people
physically being there has opened up
i think it's going to be unbelievable i
think it's going to be the one great
once
i love the concept of one step back two
steps forward i think this can be a huge
two step forward for the most
innovative venues organizations leagues
there's a huge opportunity
for access we will pay for access
that virtual give us that we can't get
otherwise
do you think this is finally the stage
where we've heard about vr for a long
time do you think this is where
that access and that virtual hybrid
comes into play from a vr perspective
i do not as of the short term
nobody on this call knows a real human
being who normally goes on vr
for an hour a day there's no normal
human
in america that goes into vr an hour a
day they're in the business
they're in b2b they're a very edge
technologist that's curious but to talk
real life
you have to wait to scale happens and
until i see humans spending an hour day
in entertainment or education and vr
i can't bet on vr
so talking about one step backwards two
steps forwards
in the sports industry what
is the most immediate uh
step that needs to be taken to take a
big step forward
to immediately right now strategize for
2022
what your virtual monetization or
branding strategy is
and have you seen a certain league or
sport
or team already sort of grabbing that by
the horns
i have not but i'm also not really
looking so it doesn't mean it's not
happening
but i'll give you i'll give you a good
one if you're a
brooklyn nets fan and in their dressing
room right next to it they decided to
create a green room confectional before
the game
and like two guys per game are
guaranteed to go in there and do q a
like this
for eight minutes prior to a game and
you get a season pass of that
for an extra uptick at 69 or 150
a ton of people are going to buy that
yeah
that's a strategy that if i owned the
jets right now i'd be implementing
right the 9 am to 10 am because i know
the football schedule
confessional in the locker room we
guarantee you two you might get more
we're the new york jets it's a 99 pass
it's good branding we can film the
content we can distribute the content
social
and if we can get 10 000 fans it could
start meaning to be a little nut it
could be a little nut
totally so i think uh it's time to pull
up our first
uh panelist to ask a question eric from
the university of south carolina a.d
i'm going to ask you to unmute now and
ask your question
i appreciate it gary uh hope you guys
can hear me okay
you've talked about uh empathy as a
super power before
in marketing but i've struggled to see
how you can deliver empathy
at scale when we have 15 000
accounts families that we're trying to
develop relationships with how would you
go about delivering empathy at scale
by hiring a ton more people and spending
a lot less money on the media
distribution
of the content we make
yeah i mean when i buy the new york jets
eric i swear to god
i plan on having a one-on-one
relationship with every season ticket
holder not me
but i'll be in the mix because i'm a
character but the organization
and how am i going to do that instead of
having a 17-person
sales team i'm going to have
i'll probably have that but i'm but
instead of spending
uh money on billboards and commercials
to get people to buy season tickets
in august on network television i'm
going to take those dollars
and i'm going to put it into you know
lifetime value
what i call farmers and i'm going to say
let's say you were on my team say eric
here is your 83 season ticket holders
no like they're your friends and dude
i do this all the time i'm building in
the greatest theater of scalability
right in a world where i'm an early
investor in facebook twitter instagram
i've spent the last 10 years building a
company that has 1 000 employees
i believe in this scaling the unscalable
through human beings
so i think you can do it but i but but
it's a great question
and of course technology with ai and ml
and and
you know app structures you can do a lot
of scaling
um to make the to make you effective and
efficient
but the human spirit is something you
can't
automate or fake and so i need to put
you in a position to be able to handle
83 efficiently with all the tools that
put you around you
and hopefully continue to advance that
so you can go to 96 because maybe with
ai
every time somebody emails you or texts
you with this exact question which is
just information
it can automatically reply next friday
at four you know like that will come
along
and so as ai and machine learning
advances
all of a sudden the eric can handle 813
instead of 83 and then you got something
really brilliant
i appreciate that thank you thank you
sir
next we're going to go to uh gab from
the flyers
uh gab i'm going to ask you to unmute
now too and ask your question
hi gary uh my question is
managing a team remotely what are some
tips and tricks to keep the staff
engaged feeling valued motivated
in this time when the unforeseen
future of live events coming back
um it's really wild it's a great segue
from eric's question
it's almost like the same thesis right
like for example yesterday
i just surprised jumped into like five
different meetings and just santa
claused people
right they think they're having a
regular meeting i come in i'm like hey
and i'm sending you all
a bottle of champagne see ya that's like
a good thing for a ceo to do or a leader
right uh just being there for people ra
like how big is your team
10 that's a dream for me right like to
me that's just you
over the next three weeks individually
to those 10 writing a very long email or
a slack or text
long like hey karen let's take it back
to when you first started that first day
when i spilled all the coffee on you
right and then it really ends with how
are you and you need anything for me
thank you the answer is giving a [ __ ]
awesome next we're gonna go to cooper
from
the pga gary vee good to be talking to
you my man
real pleasure coop uh my question is
what is the first thing that you do
every day and how do you parlay that
into success and it doesn't necessarily
have to be a task but how do you kind of
build on what the you know how you start
your day and make that into a successful
day
it's really funny because i actually
have a real answer not like a cliche
[ __ ] answer but it's a very weird
answer
i'm basically an operating system what i
would call like the way i
take oxygen i'm gonna my answer is gonna
be this way
i'm not joking this is not like i'm
fluffy or
eric said i'm empathy and i already said
i'm a good guy like this is real talk
now
i am so [ __ ] pumped when i wake up in
the morning and nobody called me in the
middle of the night to say something
atrocious happened
that i'm like almost shook by gratitude
that all the dog [ __ ] of my business day
almost feels secondary
right like like honestly i literally go
into immediate gratitude
and then i grab my phone and look at my
text and most of it's like this problem
in singapore this problem in london
this thing you know this jets players
not playing this week all bad news
you know like so like but because i had
that quick like
i don't think it's as like or it's not
as like direct as meditation
coupe right it's not as direct is that
but
i would say 365 days i would say 16
to 39 days a year it's like directly
thoughtful
like i'm like huh all right right
but it's my constant operating system
it's how i live my life
gotcha and then and just you know coping
with the bad stuff do you do you just
kind of
put yourself into a mental state where
you can handle that and continue to
operate while
you're thinking about the good things
and using your successes to kind of
trump all that
when i'm most struck right now i have a
crazy situation where there's a 10
million
delta between a four-year client at
vaynermedia where i was anticipating
something
and they're coming in at that level and
it's devastating it's bad for us we're a
small company
200 million is great but like and we did
it fast but it's it's meaningful
literally this happened today literally
i go into
what if they gave me 40 million but i
got a text that my mom's
in the emergency room i always always
put life's perspective as an overlay
over
business issues
gotcha love it thanks for the answer
gotcha brother
so we also have a question from carl
who's at the red sox who
is does not want to be on camera because
he's on baby duty today but i'm going to
ask it for him
um what is your recommendation
for finding a way to get whether it's
your your brand's messaging or your
brand's voice
to stand out in the clutter especially
when everyone is now trying to
vie for the same eyeballs um
[Music]
by being better and i know this is a
really important question my friends
especially since there's a lot of sports
talk going on a lot of you are private
messaging me so i'm giving you guys my
information
in here um
actually let's use uh let's use uh colin
who just hit me up
like if you want to be a new york
islanders player you need to be a better
hockey player than the rest of the world
i love when people like garyvee
everything you talk about
now it's hard everyone's doing it i'm
like uh-huh
and you know the
let me say this to everybody when it
comes to marketing
your ability to make pictures videos
animated gifs audio
written word and then understanding the
context
of linkedin facebook pinterest youtube
instagram spotify
to make that content work in the context
of the platform
from a utility standpoint but also
having the intuition and understanding
of the consumer's
psychology while they're on it right
betty tran is not the same human when
she's in her pinterest feed
than when she's in her linkedin feed
she's the slightly different version of
herself
mindset wise the picture and video you
put in there
is imperative the lack of massively good
linkedin strategy creative and media
amplification that's being done in this
room when it is
the answer to almost everyone's
questions in this room
is staggering to me the reason
eric i'm going to be able to afford 85
people doing that imaginary job
is because i'm not going to need 17
sales people i'm going to need four
because i'm so good at marketing as a
lead gen
that i'm going to be able to be more
efficient with my dollars
so that's the answer i know it's noisy
everything is
life it's called compete i love when
people are in competition
arenas like in the sports business and
like
like perplexed by competition
yes everybody wants to get that local
chain in washington to be the sponsor i
get that
and so you must be better than everybody
because it's not just you
it's not just right chanel versus the
capitals
or the nationals or the orioles or the
ravens it's also
that money could go to facebook that
money can go to linkedin
that money can go to direct mail that
money can go to the baltimore sun that
like
and by the way that's what i [ __ ]
love about this game
i love competing
so we've uh we we're looking at a lot of
the questions that were coming in
and a lot of people were talking about
when you're creating your own brand or
wanting to enhance your own brand voice
should you concentrate on scale or
should you concentrate on exclusivity of
that
brand what do you have to say to that
both work
coca-cola is a good business country
clubs that charge 500 000
a year are good businesses i think the
answer that question is self-awareness
is your product worth the exclusivity
and then do you know how to operate that
business
otherwise scale is going to be what you
want to aspire to
and how to play off that that idea of
fomo as well is something we talk about
a lot
um it's it's a good driver
for our and i have said before but
latent demand
there's a there's an interesting angle
too especially when you don't lose trust
with the community
and the consumer because a lot of you
create [ __ ]
exclusivity and and demand and then when
you're
stuck and you've still got too much
inventory and you have to get rid of it
you undermined that execution thus
becoming vulnerable crying wolf
in this industry is the biggest
vulnerability
do you have an example of how that has
led a brand
astray everybody who says limited
or this that and then have to discount
when it wasn't limited loses
the end a question for me it's about
then the strategy of
creating limitation that has demand
so that you're not forced into faking
the funk
because once you lose that trust with
the end consumer that they're just going
to wait you out or buy it somewhere else
or secondary this
you're [ __ ] vulnerable
yeah for sure there's a there's a
question that
several actual college students um
submitted talking about hold on i
apologize i'm
sorry carl m for you to put the trash
talk
logo in your back screen that's
marketing
you hacked my attention i'm impressed
brother let me know if you need a job
all right keep going a question from a
couple college students
um obviously it's a weird time to enter
the job market
uh it's a weird time to be feeling
ambitious and have
some some a lot of doubt and uncertainty
around the start of your career what do
you have
to say as far as advice for some of the
people entering the the job market right
now
you don't get to choose what era you
come out of college
right you know there's people on here
that are like [ __ ] these kids
i came out in 2008 and nine during the
great recession there were no jobs
that's number one number two you're
either winning
or losing in your perspective on life
the amount of people that are looking to
hire people to do tick tock
tick tock creative in 2021 is remarkable
and who do you think they think knows
how to do that all the young
people in the world even though they may
not
so i would argue that this is one of the
greatest years ever
to go from college into the workforce
because we have an explosion
of companies hiring content creators for
digital and social
and they assume the best ones are the
kids out of school
i think that people are going to find a
humongous humongous
market if they are thoughtful about what
they want to get into
and are not rigid and saying well i have
to get a job in this if you have some
humility and patience
and you take the jobs that are there in
front of you i think there's a huge
opportunity
another question on this sort of job
market
career sort of angle is a lot of people
are asking
what's been your most effective way to
find
motivation in in time of
either feeling stagnant or maybe feeling
uninspired or stuck
[Music]
practicality being practical about the
situation
and suffocating entitlement
i think everybody here needs to realize
that for all of us
we had the great fortune of being alive
and living in america during the prime
of its empire ship and if you look at
the history of
man over the last hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of years
the reason those kind of situations tend
to
lose their way because people get
entitled
people are like crying about things that
people would literally love to have
just a hundred years ago i mean there's
been harder times than covet
we are soft because we're an empire
and i think when you understand that and
take a step back
you can get a lot more grateful
and realize this will evolve and
the perspective one deploys against time
like this really matters
instead of being upset for what you
don't have
let's be happy for what you have a lot
of people died during this pandemic
if you or someone you love didn't that's
already a huge win
next a lot of you have rekindled
your relationships with your children or
your plus ones
others have learned that their plus ones
might not be for them in the long term
and the fact that you weren't around
each other all the time is why it was
sustainable
and as much as that may hurt i mean it
sounds silly
it's a real gift to realize that and
hopefully both those individuals can go
and become happy
there's a lot of great things that have
happened here i also want to remind
everybody
that had coveted started two months
earlier kobe bryant would probably be
alive for 50 more years
there was a lot of people destined to
die in a traffic accident over the last
year
that lives were saved because they were
stuck in their home
to me this is glass half full versus
glass half empty and that's how i
approach
these kind of conversations
it's a really really good way to look at
it and it's it's interesting to
think about it like that there's there's
also uh
changing gears slightly but i wanted to
talk a little bit about
we we hit on it slightly earlier but um
your idea of santa clausing a couple
meetings um
i love it i think it's an awesome idea
we got a lot of questions about
what separates good leaders who get the
job done
from a great one
intent
you know like what are you about you
know
i'm trying to get every person that i
have ever spent any kind of time with
to come to my funeral that is my number
one kpi
that's my number one kpi in my life my
number two kpi
is enjoying the process of trying to buy
the new york jets professionally
that's a framework that allows me to be
a great leader right
you know like it i i don't
i don't care
about anything other than legacy which
allows me to make
human decisions instead of financial
decisions every time i'm passed with
them
i also had the great luxury of being
raised
by a parent my mom and my parents were
together my dad just worked all the time
who instilled disproportionate
self-esteem in me
but also suffocated entitlement
right so i have confidence but i don't
think i deserve anything and if i
disappear tomorrow
i don't think i meant anything
regardless of the accolades i mean it
i'll have 12 hours of good r.i.p garyvee
comments and social and a story here or
two and
what right like you know like i think
when you
have humility but you layer it with
ambition
and kindness you can create a real great
formula and i think
how real what just came out of my mouth
is
is the delta between good and great
and i think i can end up being great
because i really am not joking to you
and i think a lot of people
say what i just said and don't actually
act on it
i don't think people are trickable on
the record i know people might find that
stunning
i don't think it's a sustainable game
and uh so i live by that
when you talk about when we talk about
sort of humility and being human in
in career in the workforce there's a lot
of people that get
either disillusioned or worried or
apprehensive about
needing to hit numbers and coming off as
disingenuous
or needing to
create something out of what a persona
that might not be
themselves right so a lot of questions
that we saw were
as sales reps let's look at that
specifically as a lens
how do you continue to be authentic and
genuine but also need to
drive revenue for your company by
quitting if you don't believe in what
you're selling
you can't imagine how much i love
selling because i sell [ __ ] i believe in
whether that was some weird pinot noir
from oregon when i was in the wine
business
uh whether that was the k-swiss k-swiss
sneakers i created
whether that's wine text whether that's
vaynermedia i i think it's i think
it's really hard for people in this room
if you don't believe in your product and
the thing that you're offering
you're in a shitty spot right because
now because you
inherently are not authentic the game's
over before you started
if you think you're selling somebody an
obstructed view
seat because you got to move the
inventory
or if you are trying to sell a suite and
you know they're
grossly overpriced because it's year 13
and your venue
and the fixtures aren't as nice as they
used to be
the liquor is a little diluted down
no more gray goose it's now smearing off
you know what i mean
you got to believe in what you [ __ ]
sell and and by the way
i'm not i'm not interested in sitting in
my high horse if you're actually sitting
here and saying i actually don't
but [ __ ] gary like i can't quit my job
you don't have to do it right now
but you need to recognize it's true
and you should start the process of
figuring that out otherwise
you're going to be a cliche salesperson
and they're going to feel it
yeah i think we're going to bring up the
next person now and
and uh chanel from the washington
football team i wanted to ask you to
unmute and ask your question
yeah so gary you have a very strong
message um as it relates to authenticity
so you know what advice would you give
us on how to build
authentic client relationships uh
without coming off as
phony you know i like to tell people the
truth
right now if you came to me and i was dc
wine business right and you're like look
i'm trying to get your business i'm like
i respect that
i'm like let's talk about it you know
like hey i'm about the skins
and i want to be on the field and you're
going to trick me with that and that's
going to be the real hook why i buy that
[ __ ] 80 000
sponsorship but like can you make it
worth for my business a little bit
better
you know like just real it works
and by the way you're talking to
somebody at 13 who was more full of [ __ ]
than anybody i've ever met
my i had a lot of gift of gab i was a
raw street kid that came from nothing
and i'm just trying to win
but i so i so i know what it looks like
and it and honesty and candor and
ambition and kindness and listening
listening is a beast you know i'm so
confusing to people because i talk so
much
i have a certain way of talking i'm sure
there's people here i've cursed a little
bit that don't like i respect that
i come from where i come from i am who i
am but
every minute i'm not doing this i'm
listening and in that listening
it's it's really made me powerful and i
think listening right
if you see a big business in your region
going on tick tock and going ham you're
listening
right got it so when you call and be
like carl
you're killing it on tick tock do you
want to be our first sponsor on our
pregame tick tock campaign you see where
i'm going you're innovating
you're watching you're listening you're
watching you're listening
don't come with the same playbook to
everybody contextualize that [ __ ]
next we are going to by the way carl
said radical candor and carl i look at
it as
kind candor i've got a little bit of a
slightly different tweak because candor
can be tough
because people are insecure and they get
nervous i've been throwing around
something called kind candor
which if you're gonna shoot it straight
come with compassion and empathy
and and and nice intent it's a really
important part of being a leader
if you got to tell you know if alicia
lynch has to tell somebody that they're
not performing
if you can come with kindness around
that candor you have a much better shot
because when you just go with candor
most people will take it and drive
within security and get fear-based
and it throws off the whole system
you can't do matter-of-fact candor
because ninety percent of people are
gonna start looking for a job an hour
later
because they think you're gonna fire
them in a month even though you thought
about it as a good thing
you gotta come with kind candor hey
carl you just been here six months you
know what i mean i get it you know maybe
you're struggling with covid
you know i'm here for you how do i make
it better because i'm seeing this
shortcoming
by the way on the record the greatest
vulnerability of my entire 25-year
career
candor i'm incredibly candarous on stage
like right now
and for my community but as a manager
because my father
was a mean candor deliverer i demonized
candor as a child i didn't realize it
probably the last two three years
recognition for me
and so i'm on my journey and i see the i
see the
benefits and it was a real vulnerability
candor is a vulnerability because then
you're [ __ ]
and bullshit's bad but i i just also
recognize most people struggled with
candor
so this kind candor really matters
ben conrad from the books i'm going to
ask you to on you
hey gary taking that question um my
question is i know you're super bullish
on
search through ai and voice for for
brands like
that are live event you know sports
where do you see
and how do you see us having to prepare
for that knowing that right now it's not
top of mind but it will be soon and then
i also was curious what the uh
if you had to pick a third under 30 red
today what would you buy
i would buy portuguese reds portuguese
reds are by far the most underpriced
quality red wines in the world the doro
d-o-u-r-o or the
wow d-o-a are two incredible regions but
they're so bad at marketing
that nobody really knows them they
portugal is known for port
but they're red wines that 25 bucks
rival 70
wines from france in the us so that's
that answer got a little nerdy on you
um i believe in a decade from this
moment
i will be sitting in my house and say
hey alexa what's the best deal on
tickets for the next game tonight
and everybody here needs to prepare for
that hey alexa what's the best concert
lineup coming up this month
hey alexa you know when covid's over
can you remind me to go to two baseball
games
and find me a good deal this is all
gonna happen
i think it's a decade so that's some
time but humans will always pick
lack of friction and people are confused
because right now everyone's like hey
alexa
you know you know uh play billy joel
right
it's early but to remind everybody the
number one iphone app
in the first year of the iphone was the
drinking the beer app
where it looked like because it was
early and we weren't innovating yet
alexa and google home and apple and
whoever else gets into it
are gonna be major major major players
it's going to happen it's lack of
friction it's faster it's faster for me
to say alexa
send me a pizza than it is for me to
open my seamless app right now and buy
pizza
not to mention that alexa's gonna know
or google home especially has a huge
thing
because it will know a lot of my
information i mean
google set up a meeting with ari as soon
as possible
and re is also on google home and google
infrastructure google calendars
and it literally looks at our two
calendars and sets up a meeting for us
and are both open spots ai
and voice is going to be game changing
the way that our grandparents look at an
iphone
a lot of you are going to look at ai
voice that way it's going to change your
life
and you're going to have to be prepared
for that you know
when for the ogs in here when google
came along
and customers got smarter and new
information that [ __ ] your game up
imagine now getting the perfect answer
from ai
not i'm going to spend 40 minutes to
find the best seat deal
the mathematical equation to the best
seat deal
that's a very different game in one
second because i wouldn't spend the time
looking for it i value my time too much
but
if i'm going to milwaukee on business
and the bucks are a really fun team to
watch right now and i'm like
hey alexa get me the best deal on
courtside
for mo for the bucks game when i go
there on my calendar
right it's going to be efficient
awesome thank you which goes back to my
bigger point which is
the challenge is going to be for us is
to make quality
products not be good at selling mediocre
products
something else that we wanted to bring
up too a lot of people were asking about
as far as not so much the tech in the
future but the trends
a lot of people asked about uh sports
memorabilia sports cards i know you've
been talking a lot about it recently
what is your sort of overall thought
on the trend of that industry and where
has it gone
in the last year compared to where it
might go in the next two or three
i mean sports cards are very hot because
i think they're contemporary art
for the 35 to 45 year old
contemporary modern high net worth
individual like i'm not buying a [ __ ]
jackson pollock
you know but i want a bill russell
perfect grade you know and so you're
going to see that play out
there's also a gambling element now
right you can
buy a pack of cards and pull a 500 000
zion
that's crazy full pledge gambling um
so i think that market has a really good
run you have real serious people coming
into it now
i think you're going to see a big long
wave of
prosperity in that market and it'll ebb
and flow
certain people can lose a ton of money
on it because they're going to bet the
farm on
kendrick none or or or tyler hero
or zion or john morant and unfortunately
some of those players won't become the
best players ever and
that will have liabilities to the way
people invested in them
but as an overall market i think it's
got a lot of potential and i think
you know i think for a lot of people
that are trying to create experiences
at that macro level i think cards are
incredible
and we know this everybody here knows
this like
giveaways at the stadium are really
smart
bobbleheads were a huge driver for a
while i think if people had a very smart
sports card strategy and were able to
navigate around the panini and tops
rules meaning properly and figuring out
what they can do
i think they could be incredible um
arbitrage mechanisms back to what i said
earlier being smart
right if all the upper bowl tickets
came with a limited edition
pack of cards that was exclusive to your
stadium that season
you would sell out because people are
going to arb the ebay sell through
against literally come to the games just
for the content of the card so
i think there's a lot of smart
innovation that i would think about in
that arena
what do you think about because it also
plays into two things right the
marketability of athletes
and how each league is handling that and
also the rise of
you know the robin it's been the robin
hood year everybody wants to invest
everybody wants alternative and
alternate investments
we just got a question from sam who's
asking
interesting on how the sports card and
sports memorabilia is sort of a good
indicator of the marketability of
leagues athletes and how they're doing
so you look at the difference between
the nba and the mlb
there's you know the trello card did
well
you could yes but the trout card
um if you look at the long tail outside
of trout i mean
they're you couldn't pick two leagues
that are
further apart right now in understanding
consumers
than mlb and mba
yeah it's an interesting way to look at
the trends of both
isn't it the sport it's very clear like
this is a modern american society is an
nba proper football soccer
ufc esports culture where the nfl has to
be very thoughtful
where major league baseball's in a
really shitty spot
if you're playing out 15-20 years i mean
the mlb decided to make a lot of money
with bam
in the short term digitally and create a
dictatorship that doesn't allow children
to see
content mike trout can walk down
madison avenue around naked and nobody
will know the [ __ ] he is
you know that's insane to me right and
especially baseball we
america is exploding in our latino
influence
and we are sitting with juan soto
vladimir guerrero jr
fernando tatis javier baez i mean this
is insanity
and they're doing nothing about it it's
atrocious it's the biggest reason my
brother and i have gone into the
baseball business
we expanded vaynersports into baseball
because
these kids have to make more money off
the field it's crazy
goes back to scale versus exclusivity
yes thank you matt
i didn't even pick the best player of
them all cooney jr i mean it's [ __ ]
insane
lindor i mean you know yes
it's it's it's very interesting so
literally the fact
that the third star on the bucks is more
famous than aaron judge
is ridiculous and true
baseball's lost their way and has
nothing to do with you know
and you know what the disguise of
baseball is is it's a summertime sport
it's a nice night out right you go to
the ballpark
the problem is soccer is going to take
that business i'll bet the house
25 years from now that summertime sport
activity
soccer's got a huge land grab against
that guy and gal
and kid that go to watch something
and and by the way don't let the nba
or the nfl decide to change the time of
year they play
one of the back to like people remember
the early question that was a different
was the first question about how covet
changed consumer behavior yeah
yes good okay here's one the nba
season shifted
because of covet we're having an nfl
game on a wednesday
well there's that but that's not
sustainable what is sustainable
is three or four of the most influential
nba owners saying
huh and this may or may i have no clue
but like
they might be like huh this is better am
i
and then that's a big ass problem for
baseball
it was even a good example of looking at
uh paul rabble and the
the pll a tour
league model right because wrestling in
the ice capades in the circus is a good
business and people have forgotten about
and paul did a great job and
you're going to see many more do it i
think we already saw that nwsl tried it
this year too it was
right and then connor's bringing it
we're not even talking about mma
and like celebrity box things in a
different place in our culture right
what you think you think people that
want to make money are going to just
look the other way to the nate robinson
jake paul situation
you can see every [ __ ] person you
know on the internet fight i'll probably
have to fight next year
you know so
we just got a very interesting question
on this too uh
from michael there's a digital token
aspect in esports right fortnite's
huge on it is there that equip has any
league or team
or sport by the way real quick i
apologize um
jb asked me who i want to fight just
want to give the official answer
hey tom brady just on the record if we
ever can get that fight mate so just
want to give that answer
go ahead
you were saying digital tokens yeah yeah
blockchain uh
virtual currency the whole world is
based on ip
the play do you understand how close the
mba is
to going out of business i'm so excited
to drop this on everybody
do you know how close the mba is to
going out of business
let me play it out for you because this
is a brain [ __ ] compared to the last
seven minutes of us
talking yeah the mba is so
star-oriented that if
lebron and greek freak steph
durant and let's just pick 15 of the
next
luke uh donovan mitchell zion
got together in a secret cave 30 deep
texted 30 billionaires that are not
owners of the nba
bezos shmezos
sarah blakely you know well i guess
politically
husband's involved with the hawks but
nonetheless do you understand
that if the 30 best nba players went to
dinner right now
texted 30 billionaires that are not in
the league
and said would you want to be my 50 50
jv partner
i own 50 a team you put up all the money
and you own 50
of the team that i believe the nba would
fold
interesting debate fun pot fodder but
the reason i bring that up is the fact
that nobody here said that's completely
outlandish
like that's stupid because you would
have said that if i said it 35 years ago
the fact that nobody said it's stupid
you may not agree and i'm honestly i'm
not saying it will i'm just saying it's
fascinating to me
because i believe it right everyone's
like
oh the nba is so brilliant they're doing
such a good job
in marketing their players they're so
brilliant they're so brilliant i'm like
you think the ncaa made these new rules
of kids being able to make money
or go to the league in 2023 because they
wanted to
get the [ __ ] out of here the internet
collapses the middle
the internet is distribution nothing
else is distribution
and i think we're going through
innovation that will bring twist
people and i think what i just said
about the mba is
scary close
who do you what sport do you think is
the first to crack that the nba
they're the most top-heavy yeah
and they're homies this isn't the era of
bird and magic
and jordan ewing these guys
i mean carmelo chris paul dwyane wade
and lebron might be drinking wine
together right now
as we sit these guys they don't appease
me as the fan
i need them to hate each other i hate
the way they [ __ ] do this
but i love it for them i hate it for me
the fan right
when i lose a jets game i want to punch
people in the face
but like for them as humans i love it
and i love the leverage
and i think it's scarier than people
think
and closer than people think
so i you you hit on this a little bit
before but if you had to
pick a sport and i'm including esports
in this
obviously what would you pick to
take over the vast majority of the
market share
for the over the next 10 years is it
soccer is it esports
are you asking which sport net net i'm
betting on the most
correct from a financial standpoint like
a business standpoint yes
esports it's in perpetuity scalable
and it's clearly already won right so
it's
it's not limited to physical location
right
what's better amazon or walmart amazon
now if walmart does a great job on
walmart.com right but like
the internet wins um
and so esports and
the malt is fascinated by esports and is
watching twitch
and is in consideration and it's on the
radar
we vaynersports represents a kid by the
name of booga who won the fortnite
championship he's one of the best
esports players in the world
he's more famous
[Music]
to the average 14 year old than a
stunning percentage of professional
athletes today
do you think by the way by the way um
somebody said hey gary didn't kyrie try
to do that before the bubble
yeah that's an early indication to how
close this is
michael jordan didn't cross michael
jordan's mind
but kyrie's flirting so think about that
play out the chess moves another 20
years yeah
do you think there's a world where one
of the other major sports
makes a play to create a hybrid
of an esp like you've seen mls teams
bring on
emls players right you've seen the same
thing with the nba you've seen it
around but is there a way that that
really can be married or is it one or
the other
um no i think look i think anybody has
permission to do anything
right like i think if mlb or singularly
the minnesota twins or
i think when i think life's about
execution right good call out
by late on nascar right they've done
some nice executions and they have a
different model
i think i think wrestling you know wwe
can own its
infrastructure in a different way given
the dictatorship that that firmwork is
in
you know there's you know there's
there's some things out there it's just
execution
if you're an owner of a sports you know
i'm wearing a version one
esports team this i i'm the minority
owner
of the minnesota version one team rocker
in call of duty version one in um
in rocket league version one is going to
be the holding cone the brand to be
built
you know that's that's the wealth the
owners of
you know the vikings they're my partners
and if we do a good job executing here
nothing stopped them from being good at
it right
meanwhile i don't know if bob crafts
thrilled with his investment
in his world because it hasn't gone as
well you know just depends it's all
execution
so i know we're we're almost running out
on time here so i want to
sort of try to wrap it up with a
question
on what we've talked about the trends
for the future we've talked about
more career workplace things if there's
one thing you could leave the vast
majority of the sports and live
entertainment
business that are people on this caller
here today
with advice for the future what would
you tell them
anything short of disproportionate
obsession with bringing the other person
value
is a vulnerability
the consumer has the leverage the
options are
infinite and
there's no place for audacity or
entitlement or history or how you think
it should be
this is a game of listening and
understanding what to bring people in
value
and uh i think that's the game
awesome well i want to thank you gary
for for an
awesome hour i want to thank ari for
getting this all together i want to
thank everyone for joining
we're going to be sending out a recap
recording of this video
um over the next week or so
and i want to have a everybody have a
happy holiday season and thank you gary
again so much
uh thank you uh re go team
uh thanks all of you i appreciate all
the comments i'm seeing um
i really just i wish everybody super
well i shared some of my information
throughout here uh have a great great
great holiday season and
new year's cheers youtube watcher what's
up it's garyvee first of all thank you
so much i hope you're doing super well
during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you